Не допустіть кровопролиттЯ! Зупиніть захоплення
Святошинського озера рейдерами, -
це акція протесту активісти біля Генеральної прокуратури у Києві
у березні минулого року.
Через два тижні одного з них жорстоко вбивають.
Ось тут знайшли Миколу Ярему.
Все на той час було в крові, розгардіяш.
На вулиці знайшли його телефон розбитий.
Члена громадської органібілзації "Біличанський рибалка"
Миколу Ярему вбили рік тому навесні.
Йому не було і п’ятдесяти, за професією зварювальник.
Микола саме був на нічному чергуванні на Святошинському озері,
яке його організація ще кілька років тому вирішила захищати.
Активісти прибирають територію,
випускають рибу в озеро і борються з браконьєрами та рейдерами,
які знищують узбережжя заради не зовсім законної забудови.
До них не раз приходили і погрожували люди спортивної статури.
Андрій припускає - так сталося й того дня, коли вбили Миколу.
Можливо, як варіант, вирішили залякати,
чи подати якусь,
грубо кажучи, візитку і попередження.
Можливо, перестаралися.
Слідство має своє пояснення того, що сталося,
хоча і не остаточне.
Версія, що Микола сам йшов, впав, зламав 9 ребер,
вона, зрозуміло, що нереальна.
Слідчі висувають версію, що це нещасний випадок.
Микола Ярема - один з чотирьох активістів,
які загинули в Україні за останні два роки.
В Києві вбили правозахисницю Ірину Ноздровську.
Вона розслідувала вбивство рідної сестри,
яку збив машиною племінник місцевого судді.
В Бердянську застрелили місцевого громадського активіста
і учасника АТО Віталія Олешка,
який боровся проти зловживань запорізької влади.
Того ж дня в Херсоні облили кислотою активістку
Катерину Гандзюк. А на початку літа 2018-го
на Харківщині загинув молодий екоактивіст Микола Бичок,
кий, зокрема, викривав зловживання місцевих підприємств,
які зливали каналізаційні стоки в водойми.
Миколу Бичка знайшли повішеним в лісі біля селища Есхар.
На думку харківського антикорупціонера Дмитра Дробота,
поліція від самого початку не дуже хотіла розслідувати справу
і навіть допустила зникнення кількох доказів.
Поліція одразу відкрила, як самогубство.
Лише після того, як люди
в селищі підняли шум
і почали говорити про те, що це не самогубство,
почалися протести, після того поліція перекваліфікувала.
Наразі більше поступу в правоохоронців
у справах вбивства правозахисниці Ірини Ноздровьскої
та атовця Віталія Олешка.
Принаймні, обвинувачені постали перед судом.
Але це сталося, зокрема, через численні мітинги і в Києві,
і в інших регіонах, а відтак -
більшу зацікавленість правоохоронців в високих кабінетах
в цих розслідуваннях, вважають в ГО "Біличанський рибалка".
Рік тому громадськість заявила владі,
що не заспокоїться, поки не будуть знайдені вбивці усіх активістів.
Поштовхом до активної кампанії стала загибель Каті Гандзюк у лікарні.
Деякі навіть почали своє розслідування,
що активізувало і правоохоронців.
У випадку Миколи Яреми чи Миколи Бичка такого великого тиску
з боку громадянського суспільства не було, розповідає Дмитро Дробот.
З Катею там знайдені фактично і виконавці, і посередник,
але замовника не знайдено,
як і по всім іншим справам.  Через історію Каті
розказуючи про неї, постійно говорячи про неї,
ми намагаємося
все ж таки отримати справедливість в цій країні,
щоб не було нападів на активістів, і на звичайних ж людей.
Загалом за оставні два роки в Україні було зафіксовано
не лише чотири вбивства, але й понад 50 нападів та погроз на адресу активістів.
Розслідування мала провести
тимчасова слідча комісія українського парламенту,
яку створили на вимогу громадськості.
За висновками Трансперенсі Інтернейшенел, враховуючи постійну
протидію правоохоронців, які на місцях часто пов’язані корупцією
місцевою владою та місцевими бізнесменами,
комісії вдалося багато.
Ії звіт очікують в парламенті вже улітку, і йтиметься
поки лише про найгучніші злочини проти активістів.
До інших випадків, за висновками Трансперенсі Інтернейшенел,
якщо і дійде справа, то вже після виборів нового парламенту.
Враховуючи, що кількість нападів й погроз на адресу активістів
тільки зростає, антикорупціонери вимагають,
щоб тимчасова комісія стала постійною.